temps en temps c'est un peu frustrant de
lire quelques éditoriaux mais quelle
idée ils ont quelques et bien écoutez je
les invite tout simplement à regarder
les propositions nous avons fait je suis
je suis frappé par là le caractère
protéiforme de ces de ces tensions il ya
des tensions sociales bien entendu
chacun des mesures détention et flic des
tensions religieuses nous avons un
devoir une responsabilité s'est réarmé
lesdain il faut muscler nos intérêts
généraux il faut faire en sorte qu'elle
puisse récupérer la totalité des amendes
et enfin il faut construire probablement
entre 15000 et 20000 places de prison et
le défi migratoire à jeter sur ce qui
est l'unité de la nation des failles des
fractures si on veut redonner cette
force à l'identité de ce qu'est la
france nous devons apporter à nos
concitoyens la sécurité et régler cette
question migratoire on n'a pas besoin de
ces séries les défendre on n'a pas
besoin des islamistes mais des fois il
ya des valeurs de la république
à défaut contre le racisme contre les
inégalités ne luttera contre le
changement climatique que si on
s'attaque aux causes de ce changement
comment décarbonés le transport sans
porter atteinte finalement à des
principes qui sont importants pour nous
je pense par exemple à la liberté de
circuler à la mobilité individuelle
alors maintenant moi ce que je propose
c'est que continuent d'en parler parce
que c'est important mais on agit
l'agriculture est indissociable les
paysages nous pouvons avoir confiance
que nos citoyens doivent avoir confiance
en notre culture en l'alimentation
produits ricol écoutez les agriculteurs
et acteurs du grand secteur agricole
vous parlez du monde après et de ce
qu'il faut faire pour tenir
l'agriculture peut être une solution
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et préserver les ressources
naturelles et la biodiversité
quand on leur dit de changer de modèle
canton lors de changer de concept propre
adecco tcc le temps de l'entreprise le
temps de l'exploitation n'est pas le
temps des injonctions des le temps des
ong et poser la question d'efficacité
d'action publique c'est mettre à
distance tous les dogmes nollet
prêt-à-penser les présupposés
idéologiques et se mettre dans la
situation en responsabilité de voir ce
qui marche et ce qui ne marche pas l'âme
est écrit nulle part que la démocratie
c'était la porte ouverte à tout et
n'importe quoi il fallait quelque chose
soit organisée que il des droits et des
devoirs et celle à proximité de la
décision mais de la gestion c'est la
transparence des résultats c'est
l'efficience du service public c'est
l'égalité réelle d'accès aux services
publics vous font une grande idée de
justice depuis 30 ans 40 ans pays
initiatives notamment de la gauche en a
plongé dans le grand bain du grand
marché mondial on dresse pas notre pays
sur le levier des territoires dire qu'on
est encore dans cette forme de naïveté
qui est celle de la mondialisation
heureuse que l'énergie est au coeur des
batailles mondial de souveraineté
d'économie de compétitivité de pouvoir
d'achat souveraineté avec la nation et
la patrie c'est pas le cas de l'europe
ce n'est pas cette europe là que nous
voulons nous voulons une europe qui soit
une union de nation
pour le voir dans ce domaine là c'est
vraiment l'europe notre dépendance par
rapport aux puissances étrangères en
matière technologique et derrière j'irai
quand même des enjeux géopolitiques et
le dialogue social ces fructueux essai
fructueux en période de crise ça doute
ça doit devenir krutenau
dire normal
on assiste à la fin d'un grand cycle
libéral faut protéger nos salariés
protégés des entreprises des personnes
morales les protéger les entrepreneurs
les personnes physiques je crois que les
seniors sont d'abord des forces actives
de notre société lire écrire compter
calculer c'est une base dont on ne peut
pas se passer que la voie d'accès à
l'emploi c'est vraiment l'apprentissage
il y à un manque de médecins dans tous
les territoires qu'ils soient ruraux
comme dans les villes les républicains
ce n'est pas un parti comme un autre
c'est un parti qui a gouverné la france
nous sommes un parti de gouvernement je
l'entends je lis parfois que mon
républicain on ne travaillerait pas
qu'on n'aurait pas d'idées j'invite tous
ceux qui pensent qu'aux républicains on
n'a pas l'idée qu'on ne travaille pas à
vite voilà nous commander des différents
livres et qui ont été dites à chacune de
ces conventions tout ce travail de fond
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les républicains
sont un seul le seul parti à l'avoir
fait le sel de la politique c'est
surtout de défendre des idées de
proposer c'est ce que nous faisons il ne
faut pas nous ayons de nouvelles la
france a besoin de la france de demain
c'est celle qui laissera une place à
notre jeunesse c'est celle qui
réaffirmera les valeurs de la république
c'est celle qui portera une espérance et
notre objectif à nous tous il est tout
simplement de faire en sorte que la
droite retrouve ses couleurs ses valeurs
ses convives qui serait intolérable de
2001 depuis se résumer à ce duel
mortifère entre emmanuelle maintenant et
marine il en va de notre responsabilité
collective et individuelle vous savez ça
faisait de nombreuses années qu'on
pourrait public un colonne républicain
on espérait l'autonomie du mouvement
jeunes désormais c'est chose faite grâce
à christian jacob d'hôtel dans qu'il
nous a donné cette chance oui je pense
que l'on peut gagner en 2022 parce que
on est en train de regagner par les
territoires on a rebondi aux municipales
et pas de petites manières ses 56 % des
villes qui ont été gagnés par les
équipes les républicains ça s'est
traduit par des sénatoriales gagnante
aussi ensuite c'était législative
partielle là aussi marquée par la
victoire et puis ce sont maintenant les
départementales et les régionales où on
confirme largement nos positions
[Musique]